[Music]
Grandmother died I made a
little mistake and dropped Jinrai into the outside house It's
really a girl Nui
Nozaka It's not just one mile after it fell It's
Mochizuki Tou and Mochizuki Momoya
If I was told that
I had died, I would have thought that it would have been more of a joke, but maybe it's
because I don't have much of a sense of reality
.
It ca
n't be helped,
Kajita, as
expected, I didn't think I would die at the age of 15,
but
what will happen to me?
I want
you to be
reborn in another world with those rules.
I want to
hear what you want
Is it a lie 2?
No, it's okay
, the battery can be recharged with
magical power, but in a world where magic is null and void, there is such a power.
Thank
you
By the way, it's a smartphone. Even
if you can use it, you can't directly
interfere with your original world and calling.
[music]
[applause] If
you just add it later
, it won't change even if you're
shy If it's a place where the light shines, it's
good, good, good
[music]
goo
these days
[music]
[Music] Good, good, good [Music]
Ahhh
[Music] This affable [Music]
For the
time
being, I wonder if people will tell me if I follow the road [Music] Hmm,
yeah,
yeah  Somehow
new took it but your snowy
mat
Do you think you'll use it
? That would be helpful.
[Music] It
's late afternoon and there's no food or water Even if you get to the city, you probably won't be able to use the money from your original world.
I wonder if you
got it Can you sell it by all means?
I can't
let him go,
who's going
to meet him in blue?
By the way, isn't there an inn after this
?
I'd like to secure a place to sleep before the sun goes down
.
It's printed,
so I'll know right away Thank you
A speed,
cad, silver,
tooth signboard
Fashion king the Is
it written me dee?
I'm going into a small scratched house Today, my sister, it's okay,
I don't need money
It's the girls over there who need it Wow,
we're wondering
if you can hit me with that one gold coin I
'm sorry
[music]
den
It's mine now
[music]
Your basic ability
and everything else there
[Music] It's
like slow motion me
[Music]
Jinhua City Mari is good
We'll be saved, but
it's definitely me who shattered it to pieces I
don't care.  Take it,
I broke it to surprise you
Thank you for helping me
.
My name and
name are the opposite
One moment on a good line What are you going to do in this town
?  It's an inn
Eh
[music]
I'd like to stay for a month,
but the tire check is fine.
We came to
this town to deliver the recommended deer horns at the request of the men earlier
, but we had a terrible experience,
so I objected, saying we should stop.
I have to get a
request from the proper place.I
think it's better to simply be shocked by registration.Safety
first
.
I was thinking of looking for it,
giraffe
, let's go together
.
I don't think I
'll be able to do anything about my
reading and writing.
Painted fruit juice subjugation One
crane wolf pulls the
catcher is 180,000 yen What is it?
sc Now preparations are ok Hey, as
always, Suzuyo is honored and I'm the avant-garde
.
Uh
ah ah ah
dee
Since then, I've been hunting 5 animals, but
I ended up killing 1
more.  I'm
not asking you to submit a guild
card So here are the 18 reward videos This will
complete the
quest  I think it
might be a good party for us. There aren't many
men who can easily keep up with onee-chan
.
I want you to tell me how to call you, after
all, it's inconvenient if you can't read, and you ca
n't understand the request.
I don't have
anything to do, but I'm grateful to be able to dodge it myself.
People who don't have the aptitude can't use magic
no matter what they do.
Kuretashi Nari also responded to that person
Very error
How to know if you have the aptitude [Music] in the court
This is also a stone It can
amplify,
accumulate and release magical power
If you use this, Dai
No. 2 Is it
cheap?
Mizui Oki  Taichi
Michi
This is the state in which this is activated without magic. This
magic stone created water in response to my chest opening
.
Why not?
Everyone needs to have that aptitude early on, but
if you don't have that aptitude, you won't be able to use that skill #I
If you try it, will you know if you have aptitude?
Come on, come on,
one sound example
[Music
] Come on, come on
ha A
sarcastic example
What's wrong with me
?  Moon, that's
amazing, I'm that magic stone
.
In addition, power soybeans that increase muscle strength
There are also rare things called gates that allow you to move
far away Magic that allows you to go far is very convenient, isn't it?
I've been through a lot of pain, so
I'm strong just because it's a
magic that strengthens my mind and body
.  Attribute magic is also called personal magic, and there
are very few people who can use the same
magic.So, do you know if you have an aptitude for non-attribute right now
?
I understand
, even if the magic doesn't grow hair,
there should be some kind of change, such as the seats shining a little or trembling a little
.
Here
4 This is
Qin's selling just now.It seems that
if you use the magic of the gate, you can go anywhere once.I wonder if this place
is already a wall when you use the magic.
It's a
little strange.
I've never heard of anyone who can use the flash attribute,
but there are a lot of them.
What's wrong,
tell me you'll be here after this
I'm thinking of launching a new menu at the restaurant, but I thought that
if you're a traveler,
you might know some good dishes.
If you have a good dish, please let me know
By the way, what would you like?
It doesn't come to mind,
but no, it's ice
cream, it's really
good,
don't you know ice cream?
It would be helpful if I could get
it Um, can you write down what you're going to read aloud from now on
?
Attribute
magic?  How is it?
Let me use ice cream I'll try using it again
What the hell
[music
] I got it
ani more yellow than anyone else
ani
yeah yeah yeah